now that we've all watched the first
season of the boys lesson tangle or the
plot threads left dangling at the end of
the season finale and figure out where
we stand with these comics inspired
characters and their super-powered
stories spoilers ahead the last we see a
few e he's helped his team mates escape
he leaves starlight behind at the
warehouse where they were being held so
she can try to resuscitate a train we
don't know where he was allies run to
but so far they seem pretty adept at
finding hide out from their neato huey
has grown in leaps and bounds in spite
of butcher calling him pathetic in the
season finale because huey refuses to
help him kidnap madeleine
the truth is huey is just as strong as
any character in the boys he's grown
from a young man still living with his
dad too afraid to ask for a raise at
work to an outlaw who murders a member
of the wells most prestigious superhero
team infiltrates the same team's
headquarters in a plot to bug the
conference room and purposefully gets
himself captured in the season finale so
he could rescue his new friends from
what promises to be torture and death
yes he yells I'm sorry over and over as
he fires an assault rifle of the men
guarding Kimiko
no but hey a few episodes ago he was too
meek to tell his daddy didn't like pizza
rolls give the guy a break
baby steps initially known as the female
the powerful but silenced Kimiko enjoys
her own evolution in the first season
when she's introduced in the fourth
episode she's too wild and savage for
anyone to leave and bound when a French
chief reads Kimiko we see how physically
powerful she is and the violence of
which she's capable we eventually
learned Kimiko was kidnapped by
terrorists and use of the lab rats at
first Kimiko won't even let Frankie get
near her but by the season finale she's
changed she still isn't talking much
but the boys managed to win her trust
particularly Frenchy before the black
ops team assaults the boys motel room
she's cleaned herself up and put on
makeup and she's clearly affected by the
young woman she sees in the mirror we'll
have to see if those changes of stuck in
season two being recaptured may have
thrown it back into wild mode remember
when we meet Kimiko she's a prisoner and
in the space of five episodes she's
captured two more times and nearly cut
to pieces by black noir repeatedly being
captured and sliced open probably
doesn't promote emotional openness
neither mother's milk nor Frenchy want
to be back working with butcher when the
boys begins
you haven't heard all the specifics yet
but it's clear butcher and the others
once worked with Mallory towards similar
goals but the results weren't good but
more than that's neither of them want to
work with one another mother's milk and
French cheese seem to have gallons of
bad blood between them a no small part
of it seems to be due to French his
attitude toward mother milks wife when
butcher recruits Mother's Milk he
straight up lies about Frankie's
involvement and predictably he has to
pull the two apart when they see each
other by the time they're imprisoned
together in the season finale the
warring outlaws have made peace with one
another perhaps uh speakers with milks
wife and hiding and telling him she
never wants to see him again neither of
them have anything left to lose by the
time he confronts homeland ax butcher is
completely on his own Hughie leaves them
and butcher abandon to rest the team to
their fate when he learns have been
captured hearing about homeland s
twisted relationship with Madeleine
butcher ghost the executives house and
covers her with explosives
while his finger rests on the dead man's
switch when things go sideways and
homeland that kills Madeleine himself
butcher resigned to his fate let's go of
the switch he wakes up in daylight on a
green lawn and soon learns he's
somewhere he could have never imagined
existed up until then he believed that
his wife Becca was murdered by homeland
in the season finale we learn at the
same time butcher des Becker is alive
and living with an eight-year-old boy
with blond hair and eyes that glow red
when home Landa tells him who he is
Oh butcher could possibly react to this
as anyone's guess will he be grateful
his wife is alive will that make him
more or less committed to taking down
homeland oh and votes
not to mention how's he going to survive
his confrontation with the leader of the
seven Elisabeth she was wonderful as a
manipulative and powerful Madelyn
Stillwell who somehow not only pushes
Vaught to new levels of profit but seems
to be the only person who can exert any
control over home Lander unfortunately
Madelyn makes a fatal mistake when
referring to what supposedly happened to
Becker she calls home Landers child's
death a miscarriage alerting home Lander
that he and his lover Jonah Vogel bomb
didn't get their story straight just
before he hollows out her skill with his
eye beams homeland that tells Madelyn he
managed to squeeze the truth out of
Vogel bomb that both mother and child
survived save for home Lander himself no
character's death could have had more
potential impact on future seasons and
Madeline's she may not have had
superpowers but throughout the first
season we learned just how important
Stillwell was not only was she the only
person who could rein in homeland err
she was pretty skilled at manipulating
the government officials who stood in
her way shortly before her death bought
big cheese mr. Edgar makes it clear he
sees her as his potential successor with
Madeline gone everything's up in the air
not to mention that both bought on the
homeland they will find themselves in
the bind if they can't explain exactly
how she died in the beginning of the
boys we get the notion that homeland er
is a powerful weapon but the one pulling
the trigger is Madeline Stillwell by the
season finale
we've learned that isn't quite true but
homeland oblasts a Baltimore mayor's
private plane out of the sky at the end
of the series premiere after the mayor
blackmails Madeline it eventually comes
to light the home lander was working all
on his own when a super terrorist shows
up in a season's penultimate episode it
destroys the boys plan even though
butcher had previously brought a sample
of the infamous compound v2 the CIA the
government isn't willing to go after the
war because they need the corporation
Supes to fight these new super-powered
enemies well you could hardly be blamed
for assuming powered up terrorists was a
common white vote conspiracy we learn it
was her homeland as planned to force a
government to let superheroes work for
the military we have villains all over
the globe
but only we can faint now Madeleine is
dead the bots oops a green LED fact of
service and there was no one left to
keep homeland are in check he was
already the most physically powerful man
in the world now home Lander is getting
close to becoming powerful in other ways
the last person has said no to home
Lander is dead and that his hands on
eyes whatever what happens if there's
twisted Superman stops taking orders
from votes from the military from anyone
we meet dr. Stan Edgar for the first
time in the first season finale of the
boys
he gives Madeline a bonus for helping
get the military contracts approved and
he makes it clear he's interested in her
becoming his successor but Madeline
doesn't survive the season finale and it
makes us wonder exactly how vote will
recover from losing one of their most
effective executives without still well
boss most powerful and influential hero
to need a replacement Handler and that's
handle Oh will have the challenge of
trying to control the physically most
powerful people in the world with fewer
cards in their hands than ever home
Landorus learned that he can not only
manipulate just as well as his dead
lover
but he can even kill vortex acute ears
with impunity when a man can lift
mountains and burn off body parts by
looking at them
what votes executive will be able to
rein him in and if no such person can be
found what happens to force as home
Lander pushes the envelope further he's
going to see vault and the rest of the
severed is less and less important
by killing Madeline her land that may
have set a time bomb within his own mind
and within vault itself when we leave
starlight she's acting more like an
actual superhero than any other member
of the seven a train would probably kill
Huey but his heart gives out from his
continued use of compound V even though
his survival could mean her losing a
spot on the team imprisonment or even
death starlight is performing CPR on a
train the last time we see her a train
no star lights helped Huey escape and if
he survives and tells homeland ur things
won't go well for star lights there are
other possibilities a convenience of a
bit predictable outcome would be that a
train survives but is unconscious for a
long time can't remember what happened
right before his heart attack or both
there's another potential outcome and it
depends on exactly who starlight has
become earlier in the episode sighs as a
conversation with Queen Maeve who tell
starlight she was just as idealistic
when she first joined the seven but kept
giving away pieces of herself until
there was nothing left it's a
conversation that convinced the
Starlight to come to Huey's aid and
there's a conversation that may save a
trains life when Huey leaves a warehouse
starlight could easily just stop trying
to save a trains life consider
what's in store for her should a train
survive the thought must be a tempting
one if she gives in to that temptation
she may get closer to the position Mavis
been in for years the Wonder Woman asked
Queen Maeve is one of the most
conflicted characters we meet and the
boys she tells herself she gave up
trying to be a real hero long ago but
throughout the first season we see
glimpses of her desire to change
she tries and fails to get home lunder
to save at least some of the passengers
of the doomed flight 37 in Episode four
guilt-ridden over the events she visits
her ex-girlfriend Elena but later
rebukes her when homeland ah finds out
about fury and erroneously think
starlites helped him infiltrate vault on
purpose it's maid who steps in and
defends her all right you want her you
got her she's your responsibility now I
just hope you're right about her for
well tier six in the season finale when
may finds a drunk star like getting sick
in the ladies room for the first time
she shows genuine sympathy for teammates
May Eve opens up to the younger hero and
tells her that she really did care when
she first joined the seven but years of
compromise and giving away pieces of
herself turned her into something else
she urges starlight to be herself
because at least one of them should be
whatever's coming in future seasons of
the boys Maeve may be the key element in
any struggles against homeland err she
clearly isn't ready folk and revolt
against the more powerful soup but she
may very well be getting close
by the season finale the deep has no
allies left her glance' hates him for
informing Madeline he's responsible for
killing the baltimore mayor he's exiled
to relatively crime-free Sandusky Ohio
after his disastrous attempt to spring a
dolphin from a water park
all of this pales in comparison to the
fact that he forces himself on starlight
in the premiere episode in Sandusky the
tip is even more useless than ever and
when word comes in at the governmentís
greenlit Supes for military action he
assumes his time for adem chin has come
but his Sandusky handler assures him for
once a fish man to stay exactly when
years when we last see the deep he's
freeing himself from her first he shaves
all the hair off his chest and nags he
hesitantly buzzes all the hair from his
head so what is the d p-- doing well
what's one of the biggest differences
between a man and a fish hair
perhaps this low-rent Aquaman no longer
sees any options for himself on the
surface world
maybe the deepest planning to run away
to the places named after he seems to
have pretty stimulating conversations
with doomed dolphins and groceries
lobsters so who knows maybe he'll be
happy who's her men but you end up here
in the beginning of the boys butcher and
Hughie are looking for vengeance but by
the end of the first season is clear
their quest may eventually have a much
more important goal we now know that the
only were the terrorists oops expose the
compound be done so just so the seven
would have an excuse to join the
military but then it was home Lander who
was behind it all by the end of the boys
first season the stakes have gone far
beyond the profit margin of force or
violent emotional catharsis of butcher
and Huy homeland there is now a threat
on a global level the ragtag team of
revenge seekers mercenaries and
traumatized lab rats may be the only
thing standing in the way of global
annihilation this is never gonna stop
it's just gonna be more blood and
awfulness
that's tough game check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos but your favorite shows
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]